The power structure at
The Morning Show
is shifting with the new voices
and younger generations.
We have some fabulous
new cast members.
We have more
incredible storylines,
we have new amazing characters.
Okay, should we have the
conversation about Bradley
that I think we're all thinking?
Is she really cutting it?
Greta came in and just swooped
us all off of our feet.
What I want is to
change things here.
Stella Bak is the youngest and
only female news president in
the history of UBA.
I want to build things but I
can't build them if the
ground isn't level.
She's essentially the new
Cory Ellison, so there's
no reason why they would get
along and see eye to eye
and they definitely do
butt heads.
Her point of view seems to be
you're lucky to have me
clear the wax out of your
ears so you
can hear what I'm telling you.
UBA's New Year's Eve
extravaganza
tomorrow night live.
I've spent years putting on a
suit pretending
to be a fake news anchor
so transitioning
over to The Morning Show was
just an extension.
And action!
I was asked to submit my
audition tape during my
sister's wedding.
I call mom, I said will you sing
with me really quick?
We did a little duet together,
and that was the weirdest
audition tape
I've ever put together
in my life.
The top trending topic this
morning is Alex Levy.
When Ty comes into this world
he's new and fresh
and he's not involved
with the internal games
and mechanics of trying to get
up the ranks of UBA.
Hello.
Who are you and how
did you get in here?
Oh that's Ty Fitzgerald he's
actually on the show.
I know who that is.
I was really nervous to
act opposite Jen.
I really am so looking forward
to working with you.
Well I'm really excited to be
worked, uh, with- worked with.
Yes.
She was so friendly and so
supportive that
I forgot about
all my anxieties.
Well look who's here.
Julianna Margulies is an
incredible addition to the show.
There she is.
Here I am.
She's brilliant and so talented.
She was on "ER" and
I was on "Friends"
and our stage doors opened
and we'd chat with each other.
Who would've thought
twenty-five years later
we'd be, finally on
the same set?
Alex if you're ready.
My character, Laura Peterson,
is the network's golden ticket.
She can pretty much do
anything she wants.
What was the nature of your
relationship with Mitch Kessler?
You never see anything like it,
someone coming in so
well-prepared take
after take, after take.
It's just quite impressive.
It was an incredible experience,
coming into this show where
everybody on this set is a
master of their craft.
Jumping into this vat of
incredibly talented women,
it was an embarrassment
of riches.
I'm so excited to come to work
and to get to do it with
these people who I love,
It's a total dream.
♪♪